le 25 avril 2002 il y as foule à la cour
d'assises de nancy
journalistes et badauds se pressent pour
apercevoir le présumé d'épaisseur du
canal
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que l'homme assurent le spectacle
voilà quelqu'un alors il s'habille
n'importe comment une espèce de veste
bariolée une cravate bariolée on croit
presque un clown il faut fahren jeu j'ai
le souvenir d'un
d'infos faron
c'est sûr de lui
[Musique]
jarville dans la banlieue de nancy en
lorraine 30 mai
1999 ce dimanche matin il est 6 heures
et sur les rives du canal des pêcheurs
installent leur matériel
mais ce jour là ne sera pas un jour de
pêche ordinaires
par accident un pêcheur fait tomber sa
canne à pêche à l'eau il se penche alors
pour la ramasser et aperçoit une masse
blanchâtre qui flottent à la surface
[Musique]
ils pensent d'abord un morceau de viande
mais lorsqu'il parvient à s'approcher il
retient un cri
il s'agit d'un pied
c'est un pied droit découvert par un
pêcheur qui alerte donc les policiers
là il ya quelqu'un au rassemblement cas
qui est dans le pied dans le canal il
faut essayer de trouver ce que c'est
mais aussi surprenant que cela puisse
paraître aucune enquête n'est ouverte
car retrouver des restes humains dans le
canal n'est pas quelque chose
d'exceptionnel il arrive relativement
souvent que des restes humains soient
découverts dans ce canal là ça peut être
un accident où il ça peut être un
suicide et comme il ya quand même un
trafic de péniches relativement
important il y avait la possibilité que
le corps était déployée par d alice des
bateaux le pied est confiée à l'institut
médico légal de nancy en attendant
d'être autopsiés
[Musique]
le lendemain à 500 mètres de l'endroit
où l'on a retrouvé le pied un éclusier
fait à son tour une macabre découverte
bloquée contre la porte de lécluse dans
l'eau stagnante flotte une tête humaine
et plusieurs ossements
[Musique]
là une série macabre va qu'il y avait
une tête sediba voilà bon c'est un peu
j'ai à la fin il y aura peut-être un
cada les jours suivants le feuilleton
macabre se poursuit un peu plus loin
dans une autre écluses
d'autres restes humains flottent à la
surface
et parmi eux une main coupée net
cette fois tout le monde se tourne vers
le médecin légiste il faut faire parler
ce corps
[Musique]
l'ensemble des restes humains découverts
dans le canal est examiné par l'institut
médico légal de nancy et les conclusions
du dr peut-on sont catégoriques il ne
peut s'agir ni d'un accident ni d'un
suicide
l'hypothèse du corps d'une personne qui
tombe à l'eau et qui secondaire mans est
broyé par les hélices de bateau était
totalement exclure
une hélice à n'a jamais des bords
tranchants s'est légèrement arrondi ça
va broyer effectivement le corps de la
victime mais en l'occurrence ça ne va
pas la décapiter de façon nette et ces
coupures net ne laisse pas de doute le
corps a été découpé avec des outils
la personne avait utilisé une scie et
avait utilisé également un élément
tranchant puisque notamment les éléments
comme les tendons avaient été sectionnés
de façon très très net c'est un travail
humain qui a donc eu quelqu'un derrière
il ya l'hypothèse du boucher parce que
son but il s'est vraiment coûté très
faim voire même au scalpel autre
révélation de l'eau d'opci les ossements
repêché n'appartiennent pas à la même
personne en fin d'examen et découverte
d'une troisième rotule pouvait nous
permettre de conclure à l'existence au
minimum de deux victimes danser
a soumis à notre examen on se dit mais
ça veut dire que plusieurs personnes
c'est troublant qui en est plusieurs à
coude alors là on veut savoir ce qui
s'est passé et là il ya eu de la tente
pour savoir le problème c'est que
l'identification des restes humains qui
ont longuement séjourné dans l'eau est
presque impossible
seul espoir la main repêché près d'une
écluse elle est décomposé mais il existe
un service à l'institut médico légal de
paris qui s'est spécialisée dans la
restauration des empreintes digitales
les policiers lorrains vont donc lui
envoyer la main ça un fils vraiment
ténue qui est tirée par les enquêteurs
et à l'époque ça fait penser vraiment à
presque une enquête scientifique tels
qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui qui par
trois fois rien pour aboutir à une
réalité et après plusieurs heures de
travail les spécialistes parisiens
réussissent un miracle la main coupée
livre une empreinte le collègue qui sont
déchargées a fait un travail
extraordinaire
on ne pensait pas qu'ils obtiendraient
un tel résultat toujours est il que ces
travaux ont permis de relever les
empreintes digitales donc de la main en
question
le srpj de nancy est chargé de la faire
l'enquêté confiée au commissaire claude
godfrain les policiers vont comparer
l'empreinte fournis par la médecine
légale au fichier national des
empreintes digitales et un nom apparaît
alors en ce cas c'est en tout cas ce n
est un chauffeur de poids lourd allemand
âgé de 55 ans et s'il figure dans les
fichiers de la police sait qu'il possède
un casier judiciaire
heureusement qu'il s'agissait des repris
de justice et par conséquent de
quelqu'un d'autre avait dans les
fichiers les empreintes digitales
si on n'avait pas eu ces empreintes
digitales dans les fichiers on n'aurait
peut-être jamais identifié sept victimes
en ce cas scène a été incarcéré en 1997
à la maison d'arrêt de saint mihiel pour
des affaires d'escroquerie de vol donc
il était élargie de la prison de
saint-mihiel au cou dans le courant de
l'année 1998 c'est tout ce qu'on sait
nous le calme en les ossements retrouvés
dans le canal appartiennent à anz
ghassen à l'exception de la fameuse
troisième rotule
les enquêteurs décident de fouiller dans
le passé du chauffeur de poids lourd
allemand pour découvrir les raisons de
sa mort
[Musique]
puisque en ce cas ce n était tellement
en toute logique c'est en allemagne que
les policiers français poursuivent leur
enquête et voici ce qu'ils vont
découvrir
et personnes en allemagne sont tenus de
déclarer leur domicile ce qui fait que
assez rapidement nous apprenons que
ghassene a été hébergé peu de temps
après sa libération en
1998 par un de ses amis qui s'appelle
hans müller et il a été hébergé au
domicile de hans müller à salzgitter
près de l'ancienne frontière d'avec
l'allemagne de l'est hans müller s'est
aussi
l'individu qui était incarcéré à saint
mihiel on ne sait rapidement également
il a été condamné en france pour des
braquages et vols à main armée
en dessous muller a donc héberger son ex
codétenu anz gassen quelques semaines
avant que celui ci ne disparaissent
et plus troublant encore c'est qu'il a
signalé cette disparition à la police
allemande avec un empressement un peu
surprenant
muller a signalé la disparition de son
ami ghassen dès le 22 mai 1999 on
pouvait se demander pourquoi tant de
précipitation a déclaré la disparition
de son ami qui était parti je crois à la
veille et simplement la veille au matin
de son domicile alors là s'arrête 30
secondes si
un quidam tout à fait normal un citoyen
lambda peut s'inquiéter la disparition
d'un ami qui n'arrivent plus à joindre
au téléphone oui il va aller à la police
là on a quand même à faire des personnes
qui sortaient des tensions qui ont été
condamnés pour des multiples trafics
donc quand même des gens du milieu très
clairement c'est pas du tout le réflexe
de gens du milieu que d'aller signalé la
disparition de l'un d'eux dans un délai
aussi proche les policiers se pose des
questions muller at il un lien avec la
disparition de son ami gassen s'agit-il
d'un règlement de comptes entre anciens
détenus la question qui se pose pour les
enquêteurs à ce moment là c'est de
savoir si le gars découvert découpé dans
le dans le canal a été liquidée au fond
par la personne avec qui traficotait à à
l'époque la question est est en l'air et
c c'est une des premières hypothèses les
policiers français font une demande de
commission rogatoire pour interroger
hans müller qui vit en allemagne mais en
attendant que les formalités aboutissent
ils vont interroger son téléphone
la police allemande fournit les relevés
téléphoniques de hans müller et l'équipe
du srpj de nancy va découvrir que le
jour même de la disparition de son ami
muller a appelé avec insistance certains
numéros de téléphone en france
il ya d'abord une douzaine d'appels
passés auprès d'un certain philippe
grossiord
l'homme habiterez à laxou dans la
banlieue de nancy il serait le gérant
d'une société de transport au statut un
peu douteux inter europe diffusion
ont fait un certain nombre de
vérifications sur le sur place à partir
du 19 juillet on voit effectivement
qu'il y à une boîte aux lettres au nom
de
confirmer également une boîte aux
lettres au nom de la terre europe
diffusion qui est qui correspond à
l'identité de gros support pour registre
du commerce puis vous ne trouver trace
nulle part de d'inter europe diffusion
puis bon quand vous voyez le pape hier
en tête avec des fautes d'orthographe
des numéros complètement bidon
pas
me tromper que
néophyte
la société inter europe diffusion et
donc fictives
quant au nom de grossiord il rappelle
quelque chose aux policiers qui vont le
retrouver dans de vieux dossiers
reçus aurons c'est un
nom qui est connu des services de police
judiciaire on sait que c'est un alias
habituellement utilisé par un escroc qui
était lui-même condamné à plusieurs
reprises pour diverses escroqueries et
cet escroc est identifié rapidement
comme étant nadir sedrati
nadir sedrati c'est un petit malfrat de
la région il a l'habitude d'emprunter de
faux nom pour couvrir d escroquerie à
l'assurance ou des détournements
bancaire au total dans sa carrière plus
de trente ans il a quinze condamnations
pour ces faits là de d'escroquerie ou de
d'identité d'usurpation d'identité
coïncidence troublante les enquêteurs
s'aperçoivent que l'homme possède un
point commun avec la victime et avec le
principal suspect
on s'aperçoit que sedrati a été écroué
au centre de détention de saint-mihiel
en même temps que müller et ghassen donc
le lien est effet le lien était évident
on se rend compte que des comptes a pas
une porte dans ce dossier on tombe sur
quelqu'un qui a fait de la prison donc
ça donne déjà à d'éclairage sur le
dossier et sur la sphère
sedrati ghassen et muller se connaissent
donc parfaitement
les policiers se demandent si après leur
libération les trois hommes ne sont pas
restés en contact
préparait-il tous ensemble un mauvais
coup on ne va pas tarder à s'apercevoir
que nadir sedrati le personnage central
du triez
dans les relevés téléphoniques de hans
müller fournies par la police allemande
il y à un deuxième numéro de téléphone
qui revient plusieurs fois il s'agit du
numéro d'une cabine téléphonique située
dans un foyer de réinsertion pour
anciens détenus le foyer stoffer située
en banlieue de nancy
le commissaire godfrain et envoie une
équipe
clos foyer stauffer se trouve à peu près
à vol d'oiseau à 200 mètres du lieu du
premier lieu de découverte des morceaux
de corps
sedrati alliance grossiord on a tout de
suite sa photographie elle est aux
archives donc muni de sa photographie on
va au foyer est offert en amont trop
directeur qui nous identifient
immédiatement sedrati nous dit mais lui
c'est un gars qui a logé au foyer sauf
il a sa chance
cette nouvelle piste aboutie donc encore
une fois à sedrati
pour les policiers il ya donc désormais
deux suspects hans müller et nadir
sedrati il devient urgent de les
interroger
[Musique]
le 21 juillet 1999 à 7 heures du matin
les policiers français et allemand
s'apprête donc à intervenir
simultanément les premiers aux deux
adresses de sedrati son foyer de
réinsertion et le siège de sa société
fictive
les seconds au domicile de müller à
salzgitter banks muller lui il est
interpellé avec le concours du hk un
service un service de d'interpellations
à ses muscles et en allemagne
on sait pas qui on sait pas qui peut
être la réaction de müller on sait que
c'est un braqueur donc on prend les
policiers allemands prennent des
précautions
seulement contre toute attente hans
müller ne fait aucune difficulté bien au
contraire il semble abattu lorsqu'il
apprend que le cadavre de hand cassone a
été retrouvé assez vite on s'est rendu
compte d'abord que müller ne savait pas
gaza d'été bord et ensuite qu'il
éprouvait je crois de l'amitié pour gaza
n'est qu' il était assez touchés par sa
disparition
l'appartement de hans müller est passé
au peigne fin mais on y trouve peu de
choses intéressantes à l'exception de
quelques vêtements laissés par cassen et
qui semble indiquer que l'homme avait
prévu de revenir
[Musique]
au même moment en france à laxou
l'équipe du commissaire godfrain
débarque au siège de l'entreprise de
nadir sedrati et là aussi le suspect est
interpellé sans difficulté
ce drap ti est interpellé quand il sort
de chez lui à 7 heures du matin
on s'apprête à monter à son appartement
quand il sort de l'ascenseur boulou
donc on a sa photographie on le
reconnaît immédiatement on lui dit
monsieur sadrati bon c'est la police
judiciaire on a besoin de vous poser
quelques questions
on interpelle sans problème il est
surpris de nous voir qui se laisse
arrêté sans difficulté
les hommes du srpj monde alors avec lui
pour perquisitionner son studio et ils
sont loin d'imaginer ce qu'ils vont
découvrir
on retrouve
un détour
c'est quand même assez surprenant dans
une cuisine mais surtout on retrouve une
broyeuse à végétaux toujours la cuisine
j'ai une machine et à ses hôtes qui fait
un mètre d'eau imaginez électrique qui
manifestement 1,9 mais qui a été
vraisemblablement utilisé puisqu'on
trouve à l'intérieur quelques quelques
débris d'une matière brunâtre également
bizarrement on trouve des outils
deux sites bouchée des couteaux des qui
manifestement sont souillés par des
taches ou des traces de matières
c'est pas si c'était du sang humain
aussi c'est quelque chose d'autre qu'on
ne sait pas
les policiers sont également surpris par
de nombreuses taches brunâtres sur
l'évier le carrelage les murs et même le
sol
il y à des tâches de sang sur fait des
traces de sang sur une plainte de
de la cuisine on continue à chercher et
en soulevant le linoléum de la cuisine
on est immédiatement frappé par une
odeur nauséabonde qui
kira kira monfreid
manifestement c'est dû sans aucune
réflexion avancée qui se trouve sous le
linoléum
nadir sedrati assistent à la scène
menotté au siège de son bureau
l'homme semble impassible et reste mais
il garde son calme et garde son sang
froid
nous prend un peu de haut en disant
qu'on est en train de le faire n'importe
quoi que ça ressemble à rien elle ceci
cela
après plusieurs heures de perquisition
les enquêteurs font une découverte
supplémentaire
caché dans un coussin du un canapé un
petit bocal d'un litre environ
groupement une une poudre blanche
dégageant une forte odeur
d'amande amère ainsi qu' un petit tube
quelques dizaines de ram d'une substance
identique
on se demande ce que c'est bon bien
évidemment on y goûte pas y'a que dans
les films qu'on voit
les gaules est du good sain pour savoir
si cette la coop de l'héroïne autre
chose
le commissaire godfrain envoie
immédiatement cette substance au
laboratoire pour analyse
mais la perquisition n'est pas terminée
dans la pièce qui sert de bureau pour la
société de transport fictive inter
europe diffusion les policiers et
peluches de nombreux documents qui vont
leur semblait douteux on trouve un
nombre impressionnant de documents
d'identité on trouve des documents
l'ordre de stijl gérard ou non de
renforts norbert ces deux noms étaient
jusque là inconnus des enquêteurs
gérard stèle né à paris en 1944 et
norbert ronfort né en 1939 dans le
territoire de belfort
qui sont ces deux hommes des complices
de nadir sedrati ou bien des victimes
ont ils eux aussi mystérieusement
disparu donc c'est la deuxième question
des enquêteurs c'est ah bon mais y
aura-t-il d'autres personnes aussi
concerné dans cette affaire quels sont
les liens entre les trois femmes bref
tout s'ouvre à ce moment là des outils
tâches et des traces de sang
une mystérieuse poudre blanche et des
papiers d'identité
après 10 heures de perquisition la liste
des éléments retrouvés par les policiers
plutôt longue il est grand temps de
poser quelques questions à nadir sedrati
[Musique]
vers 18 heures après la perquisition de
son bureau nadir sedrati et conduit au
commissariat de nancy pour
interrogatoire
les grottes question c'est quelles sont
les liens exacts entre ses drapiers
bullaires autres sedrati et kaced
pourquoi kaced est il venu à nancy et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre ces
pratiques et cassel à la grande surprise
des policiers dès le début de son
audition sedrati se montre plutôt bavard
il ne cache ni ses activités d' escroc
ni ses arnaques nice et usurpation
d'identité
le problème c'est qu'il parlerait
presque trop il a un ventre fermeture et
dès qu'on lui présente un argument il
invente autre chose là quand même une
propension à
déblatérer parfois même des âneries mais
c'est lui-même qui le reconnaît dit
voilà c'est ma nature je parle je parle
beaucoup des fois je me contredire mais
je ne reste qu'un escroc après plusieurs
heures d'interrogatoire sedrati va finir
par reconnaître que le meurtre de hand
castle a été commis chez lui
mais le récit qu'il va faire va sembler
vague est pour le moins rocambolesque
[Musique]
la scène se déroule le 21 mai 1999
neuf jours avant la découverte des
premiers restes humains dans le canal
dans son appartement de laxou nadir
sedrati affirme qu'il reçoit la visite
de ses deux anciens codétenus
andreessen et hans müller
[Musique]
dans un premier temps
il dit avoir reçu la visite
de ghassen et de müller à son domicile
là-dessus serait venu de hollande et de
marocains
[Musique]
selon sedrati la réunion a pour objet un
trafic de drogue seulement très vite la
discussion aurait mal tourné et le ton
serait monté
et c'est ainsi que antiga scène aurait
été tué
pour quel motif sedrati ne le précise
pas ces individus se sont disputés avec
gas and qu'à ce moment-là lui sedrati
serait partie de l'appartement
la scène aurait été tué par les
hollandais ou les marocains
[Musique]
muller se serait chargé de la de se
débarrasser du corps etc étaient rares
à en croire sedrati il serait donc un
simple témoin dans une affaire de
règlement de comptes entre trafiquants
de drogue mais les enquêteurs ne sont
pas convaincus par cette histoire ils
pensent que sedrati leur cache quelque
chose
l'interrogatoire se poursuit et les
policiers décident de brusquer le
suspect il lui annonce que le corps de
hans gaza n'a été retrouvée coupée en
morceaux dans le canal et à ce moment-là
nadir sedrati perd son sourire et se
montre beaucoup plus nerveux il fini par
délivrer une nouvelle version des faits
et donne cette fois le nom de l'assassin
hans müller l'ami de gars scène c'est en
fait muller qui se serait disputé avec
ghassen et qui aurait tué cassen en lui
donnant à part un coup de couteau
néanmoins à chaque fois sedrati dit moi
je n'étais pas présent au moment des
faits je me suis engueulé avec eux je me
les armes a demandé de partir comme je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
mais c'est simplement que müller m'a
demandé où il pouvait se débarrasser du
corps donc c'est moi qui lui indique
effectivement qu'on peut se débarrasser
d'un corps dans le canal
cette fois le récit de sedrati semble
crédible car muller a une réputation
d'homme violent et il aurait très bien
pu tuer son ancien compagnon de
détention
par ailleurs les éléments matériels
découvert pendant la perquisition
corrobore cette version le sang retrouvé
sur le sol serait celui de ghassen la
poudre blanche pourrait confirmer le
trafic de drogue
[Musique]
aussitôt informés par leurs homologues
français les policiers allemands
confronte hans müller à cette accusation
et l'homme est catégorique il n'a pas
tué ghassen
muller c'est pas le genre de type à les
raconter sa vie au premier flic devenu
donc
il hésite à dire tout ce qu'il sait ça
c'est évident il est plus en
contradiction dans ses explications à
nombreuses reprises donc on sait que
monsieur muller ne dit pas la vérité
muller mans et les policiers allemands
ne vont pas tarder en avoir la preuve
ainsi il affirme qu'il n'a plus aucun
contact avec nadir sedrati depuis sa
sortie de prison or ces relevés
téléphoniques prouve le contraire on
peut y lire que müller et grossiord
alias nadir sedrati se sont appelés le
jour même de la disparition de hunt
ghassen le 21 mai devant les éléments
qui l'accablent muller va alors cédé un
peu de terrain
muller confirmé aux policiers allemands
qu'ils montaient des arnaques avec
sedrati mais qu'il ne dit pas pourquoi
ghassen est allé
allez voir ce natif muller reconnaît
donc les coups de fil mais refuse d'en
dire plus et il maintient n'avoir aucun
rapport avec la mort de ghassen
malgré les zones d'ombré de ces
déclarations les policiers allemands ne
dispose pas de suffisamment d'éléments
pour mettre müller en détention l'homme
est relâché
en france sedrati lui ai mis en examen
pour le meurtre de hunt ghassen à cause
des traces de sang retrouvées chez lui
incarcéré à la prison charles iii de
nancy il continue d'accuser muller
alors qui a tué muller sedrati ou les
deux ensemble
c'est la mystérieuse poudre blanche qui
va livrer les clés de l'énigme
[Musique]
deux jours après la perquisition les
policiers du srpj de nancy reçoivent les
résultats des analyses scientifiques et
là à la grande surprise des enquêteurs
la poudre retrouvé dans l'appartement de
nadir sedrati n'est pas une drogue mais
un poison mortel
le bocal d'un kilo de poudre blanche
toujours c'est du cyanure de potassium
les enquêteurs pensent qu'ils ont
peut-être trouvé l'armé du crime une
dose infime de cyanure de potassium peut
suffire à provoquer une mort presque
instantané il demande qu'une expertise
spécifique car le cyanure est connu pour
laisser des traces dans les cadavres
même longtemps après la mort
de monde donc où la bo de nous faire des
analyses toxicologiques
approfondie sur non seulement les
prélèvements effectués au domicile de
ses ratés mais également sur tous les
morceaux de cadavres retirés du canal et
là bingo qu'on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
présence en quantité non négligeable de
cyanure
dans les morceaux retirer retrouver
cette fois plus de doute en ce cas ce n
est mort empoisonné
nadir sedrati a menti aux enquêteurs
les policiers de nancy pense que l'achat
d'un kg de cyanure n'a pas dû passer
inaperçu ils vont donc essayer d'en
remonter la trace le cyanure de
potassium aussi dangereux soit il est un
produit qui est en vente libre il suffit
de donner son nom pour en obtenir auprès
des établissements habilités à le
commercialiser
donc on fait des recherches sur le plan
régional et on trouve des établissements
dans une zone
commerciale de la proximité de nancy
qui confirme avoir vendu 1 kg de cyanure
à un monsieur
royer
dans le courant du mois de mars 1999 un
individu a téléphoné à la société en se
présentant comme monsieur royer
demandant s'il était possible d'obtenir
rapidement du cyanure de potassium
ce monsieur royer est inconnu des
services de police mais par chance il
figure dans l'annuaire
convoqué au commissariat l'homme ne
comprend pas il ne s'est jamais procuré
de cyanure et n'a aucun lien avec l'anc
est en cours en continuant de le
questionner les enquêteurs vont
cependant finir par comprendre
joël royet n'est pas impliquée dans la
sphère en réalité quelqu'un d'autre
s'est fait passer pour lui
le vrai jo elle voyait à était lui
obligé de déposer plainte contre ces
pratiques pour des usurpations d'état
civil et cédera t avait été condamnée à
strasbourg notamment pour des
usurpations d'identité commises à
l'encontre de royer nadir sedrati
récidiviste de l'usurpation d'identité
at il acheté le cyanure sous le nom de
joël royer pour en avoir le coeur net
les policiers retournent immédiatement
au siège du grossiste
[Musique]
quand on présente la photo de celle
ratti ou m'a désigné lui pose problème
c'est bien l'individu qui s'est présenté
comme
royer agissons pour le compte d'un
terreau de diffusion qui est venu et qui
hd ce qui est l'hôte ionian question
reste une question le cyanure est un
poison au goût très amer comment sedrati
at il pu empoisonner ghassen sans que
celui ci ne s'en aperçoive le
toxicologue de la police a son idée pour
faire avaler du cyanure à sa victime
sedrati a pu tout simplement le diluer
dans quelque chose de fort comme du café
par exemple
dans le bureau de l'interop diffusion
vous avez la machine à café des états
qui sont donc ils sont là vous avez
également le petits flacons de cyanure
qui est à proximité et je veux dire que
c'est pas difficile de penser qu'il a pu
mettre du cyanure de potassium dans dans
le café de degas scène ça a dû faire
très rapidement puisqu'il faut des
quantités relativement peu importante
pour empoisonner quelqu'un quelques
jours plus tard des tests en laboratoire
le confirment les deux tasses à café du
bureau de nadir sedrati comporte
effectivement des traces de cyanure
et quand même des tasses des traces de
sang du cyanure dans cet appartement une
broyeuse du matériel de boucher ça fait
beaucoup pour un seul homme quand même
les policiers détiennent désormais un
scénario complet du meurtre de hunt
gassen et ce scénario le voici
à la fin du mois de mai 1999 nadir
sedrati aurait invité andy ghassen chez
lui à laxou
il lui aurait offert du café empoisonné
et quelques secondes plus tard
en tout cas scène se serait effondré
raide mort
sedrati il aurait ensuite découpé en
morceaux avec ces outils ce qui explique
les taches de sang
puis le soir venu à l'abri des regards
il se serait débarrassé du corps en le
jetant dans le canal de la marne au rhin
à quelques kilomètres de là
[Musique]
l'étau se resserre autour de sedrati la
police dispose de nombreux éléments à
charge mais elle n'a pas encore trouvé
la preuve irréfutable et surtout elle
n'a pas identifié le mobile pour quelles
raisons sedrati aurait-il tué son ex
codétenu
les enquêteurs comptent sur hans müller
l'ami de la victime pour débloquer
l'enquète
[Musique]
3 août 1999 hans müller est convoqué
dans un commissariat binational à
sarrebruck à la frontière franco
allemande
l'homme est tendue il va être confronté
à son accusateur nadir sedrati
depuis le début de l' enquête les deux
hommes livrent aux policiers des
versions contradictoires
mais face au juge d'instruction et au
procureur hans müller va cette fois
livré une version des faits implacable
il explique que la dernière fois qu'il a
vu son ami hand cassone la victime
c'était le 20 mai 1999 la veille de sa
disparition
la famille muller fait est justement
l'anniversaire de gars scène et on lui a
offert ce jour-là une chemise jaune en
cadeau
[Musique]
mais le lendemain matin vers 7 heures
entre muller aurait constaté le départ
de son ami il aurait alors appelé sur
son portable et c'est ainsi qu'il aurait
appris que ghassene avaient convenu d'un
rendez-vous avec sedrati chez celui-ci à
nancy garson ludique ils seront donc
chez ces pratiques comme prévu et qu il
l'appellera dès qu'il sera arrivé
effectivement gassen aurait rappelé vers
8 heures depuis le pied de l'immeuble de
sedrati juste avant le rendez vous il
aurait assuré son ami que tout allait
bien et il aurait promis de rappeler en
sortant
mais deux heures plus tard ghassen ne
rappelle pas et son téléphone ne répond
plus muller aurait fini par rappeler
avec insistance aidera-t-il lui même et
celui ci aurait enfin décroché vers midi
muller appelle le domicile grosseur
alias sedrati c'est
sedrati qui décroche et uruguay pas de
problème ghassen et là il est arrivé
donc bien évidemment muller demanda
sedrati pappas le mois et là sedrati lui
déclare bas il se sent pas très bien il
ya il est dans un fauteuil donc muller
l'uib a fait nuit un café ça lui fera du
bien et sedrati lui rétorque il n'y a
pas de problème je lui ai déjà fait un
café
pour les policiers la boucle est bouclée
le café dont parle sedrati au téléphone
est certainement un café empoisonné au
cyanure
et à ce moment là en ce cas ce n était
sans doute déjà mort
le récit de hans müller et précis et
cohérents juges et procureurs sont
convaincus qu'il a dit vrai la muller
qui ne varie pas sur ses explications
donc pour avoir un passé judiciaire
chargé et crabes un personnage qui la
donnent le sentiment de dire vraiment
comment les choses se sont passées et
d'avoir toujours la tristesse de
lasbordes sur de bigard scène d'ailleurs
les relevés détaillés de hans müller
confirme les nombreux coups de téléphone
passés à sedrati ce jour là
aux yeux des enquêteurs l'homme est
définitivement innocentés en revanche
nadir sedrati est en difficulté ces
explications deviennent embrouillé il se
contredit et il n'arrive plus à répondre
aux questions des enquêteurs
rien n'explique la création de cette
entreprise fictive
rien n'explique que ghassene soit venu
dans son appart bord dit pourquoi
rien ne vient étayer b du moindre
commencement de preuve l'idée que bull
air ou d'autres personnes soient venues
dans ce minuscule appartement
pour
tu es gas aide dans les conditions que
c'est ratti raconte les policiers et le
juge n'écoute plus sedrati
et peu à peu l'homme perd son sang froid
à l'occasion de cette confrontation
sedrati
est apparue sous un autre jour
c'est à dire qu'il était à deux doigts
de sauter par dessus de la table pour
prendre müller à la gorge
cette fois sedrati semble démasqué et un
élément à charge supplémentaire va
apparaître à sa sortie de l'entrevue
à l'extérieur
la femme de hans müller rose marie
attend son mari
elle voit passer devant l nadir sedrati
qui sort de la confrontation hélas son
sang ne fait qu'un tour
car cette chemise que porte le suspect
elle l'a reconnu au premier coup d'oeil
sedrati s'était fait bout il était très
présentable il avait une belle chemise
jaune le seul problème c'est que la
chemise jaune c'était celle qui avait
été offert à ghassen par madame muller
[Musique]
cette fois pour les policiers il n'y a
plus aucun doute sur la culpabilité de
nadir sedrati
le suspect rotonde en prison pour y
attendre la fin de l'instruction mais il
n'est pas homme à se laisser abattre et
il n'a pas fini de surprendre les
enquêteurs
[Musique]
depuis son incarcération à la prison de
nancy nadir sedrati fait preuve d'un
comportement inquiétant
il déchire ses draps tente de se
suicider il semble basculer dans la
folie
[Musique]
bien comportement particulièrement
singulier en détention qui se met à
boire ses urines et à manger ses
excréments voilà je suis pas certain
qu'il ya beaucoup de détenus ou même
beaucoup d'hommes ou de femmes au
général qui serait capable d'adopter
pendant des semaines et des semaines un
comportement comme celui là mais pour
l'expert psychiatre francis bockel qu'il
l'a observé en cellule à plusieurs
reprises la folie de nadir sedrati n'est
pas réel
rapidement il m'est apparu que c'était
de la pure simulation il s'agissait pas
d'un d'un trouble psychiatrique il
s'agissait pas d'un troubles
pathologiques
manipulateur et simulateurs hors pair
sedrati n'est donc certainement pas fou
les enquêteurs pensent au contraire
qu'il s'agit d'un dangereux criminel et
qu'il peut même y avoir d'autres
victimes que hans gassen car
souvenez-vous au début de la faire on a
retrouvé une troisième rotule dans le
canal il y a donc au moins une deuxième
victime non identifié pour en avoir le
coeur net les policiers de nancy vont
prendre une décision radicale
à nancy ce matin le canal de la marne a
peut être révélé une nouvelle partie de
ces macabres secret
un canal vidé pour la première fois
depuis 1963 les recherches sont donc
difficiles et pénibles mais les
résultats sont possibles
le 3 novembre 1999 un tronçon de 3 km du
canal de jarville est pratiquement mis à
sec m à m le fonds va être fouillé la
police scientifique les pompiers les
journalistes se pressent sur les berges
tout le monde s'attend à une découverte
importante pour l' enquête c'est un
véritable événement parce que ces
gigantesques qu'il faut vider du canal
et c'est aussi un tournant dans
l'enquêté serre que les juges le juge
décide d'utiliser tous les moyens et de
pas s'arrêter en fait et ça devient une
affaire prioritaire il a les moyens de
vite et le canal
on attend ça avec impatience on se dit
mais qu'est ce qu'on va trouver dedans
fait ce qu'on va trouver 3 4 cores fait
ya vraiment là là c'est un sujet de
fantasmes et en effet les policiers vont
faire quelques découvertes intéressantes
[Musique]
un
tibia et un fémur et puis une omoplate
donc c'est pas énorme par rapport à
l'importance qu'ils avaient cette
opération
celle de vider le canal mais il ya quand
même des éléments qui vont servir après
dans cette enquête
les eaux retrouver son confié au médecin
légiste et celui ci leur trouvent de
nombreux points communs avec les
précédents restes humains repêché
sa présentait les mêmes caractéristiques
et notamment effectivement sur les oslon
fémur bassin
l'utilisation d'une d'une lame pour
couper les au tibia fémur humérus après
analyse presque tous les autres trouvées
sont attribués à hand cassen
[Musique]
tous sauf une omoplate
provient-elle du même corps que la
mystérieuse troisième rotule repêché
quelques mois plus tôt une nouvelle fois
les enquêteurs se demandent à qui
appartiennent ces autres restes humains
[Musique]
pour retrouver le nom des autres
victimes les enquêteurs de la police
judiciaire dispose d'une piste les deux
cartes d'identité qui l'ont découverte
souvenez vous lors de la perquisition
dans les bureaux de nadir sedrati des
cartes au nom de gérard stèles et de
norbert ronfort
les enquêteurs se demandent si mais ils
n'ont pas disparu aussi on sait qu'à
deux corps dans le canal parce qu'il ya
trois rotule qui ont été trouvés mais là
c'est le troisième corps c'est la
question du troisième corps qui se pose
de la troisième victime qui est posée
par ça et donc il faut remonter la piste
de ces personnes dont sedrati a pu
utiliser ou pas mais en tout cas dont il
a les papiers d'identité dans son
appartement coûte chance pour les
policiers les deux hommes possèdent d'un
casier judiciaire on va donc pouvoir en
apprendre davantage sur leurs comptes on
sait que rapidement aussi que steyn
gerra énorme et renforçons des des
personnes que socrate ya connu à la
maison d'arrêt de saint mihiel la prison
de saint-mihiel
gérard stèles et norbert ronfort ont
donc connu le même centre de détention
que hunt ghassen hans müller et nadir
sedrati le problème c'est que ce tales
et ronfort sont sortis de prison depuis
quelques mois et qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
introuvables les policiers vont donc se
lancer sur leur piste
[Musique]
les enquêteurs commencent par
s'intéresser à gérard stèle c'est un
chauffeur de poids lourd de 55 ans à
saint mihiel il achevait une peine de
quatre ans de prison et s'était remis à
chercher du travail
stijl il est domicilié dans une faille
et de ressort à 130 réinsertion à
l'antenne meinau à strasbourg il finit
par retrouver à un job dans une petite
entreprise de récupération qui avait
l'habitude de deuil d'employer des des
gens dans sa situation ce premier
contrat ne dure que trois mois mais
aussitôt après gérard stèle se voir
proposer une autre embauche apparemment
très alléchante il dit au directeur du
foyer où il était hébergé qu'on lui
proposait une place de chauffeur-livreur
avec un salaire mensuel non négligeable
qu'il devait faire l'international et
que c'était un nom sur un ex détenu qui
le pistonné pour avoir cette place là
stay annonce donc qu'il va se rendre à
nancy pour passer son entretien
d'embauché
le quitte le foyer
en affirmant quand même son directeur
donc il n'y avait aucun problème il
serait là le lundi matin pour prendre
son poste au travail mais le lundi matin
gérard stèle ne se présente ni à son
travail ni à son foyer le directeur du
centre de réinsertion est prévenu par
téléphone que le chauffeur de poids
lourd a été embauché et qu'il ne
reviendra pas le centre mais ne reçoit
un coup de fil d'un gars qui s'appelle
grossiord et qui lui dit baye gérard
stayed y reviendra pas tout de suite il
a embauché des digues définitivement il
est déjà sur les routes edit je viens
récupérer les affaires de style parce
qu'on va le juger sur nancy le
mystérieux employeur sera facilement
identifiés par le personnel du centre il
s'agit de nadir sedrati
quant à gérard stèle on aura plus jamais
de nouvelles de lui
[Musique]
lors de la perquisition les policiers
ont également trouvé la carte d'identité
d'un certain norbert ronfort cet homme
est lui aussi présumée victime de
sedrati au domicile de celle ratti on
retrouve une casquette à ses
caractéristiques
qui a été reconnu par la suite comme
étant celle portée en permanence par
norbert euro fort on retrouve également
une paire de lunettes identifier
formellement comme étant les lunettes de
norbert confort on retrouve des
documents d'identité de plus il s'avère
que c'est nadir sedrati qui est venu
chercher norbert ronfort à sa sortie de
prison il est donc la dernière personne
à l'avoir vue avant sa disparition
gérard stèles et norbert ronfort ont ils
été tués par sedrati ont ils un lien
avec les éléments matériels dont
disposent les enquêteurs
pour le vérifier les policiers vont
soumettre les familles des deux disparus
à des prélèvements adn et quelques jours
plus tard les résultats des tests en
laboratoires vont conforter leur
hypothèse l'omoplate la troisième
rotules et certaines traces de sang
trouvées chez sedrati correspondant à
l'adn de gérard stèle
les traces d'adn retrouvées sur la
casquette sous le lino du studio et sur
l'a6 à découper correspondre à celui de
norbert ronfort
après deux ans et demi dans quête nadir
sedrati s'apprête donc à répondre devant
la cour d'assises de nancy des meurtres
de trois de ses codétenus en ce cas
scène gérard stèles et norbert ronfort
bonjour une nouvelle fois la une de
l'actualité cette semaine nadir sedrati
le présumé des coupeurs du canal de
nancy
[Musique]
le 25 avril 2002 il y as foule à la cour
d'assises de nancy
journalistes et badauds se pressent pour
apercevoir le présumé d'épaisseur du
canal
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que l'homme assurent le spectacle
voilà quelqu'un alors il s'habille
n'importe comment une espèce de veste
bariolée une cravate bariolée on croit
presque un clown
[Musique]
il faut fahren jeu j'ai le souvenir d'un
d'infos faron
c'est sûr de lui
[Musique]
nadir sedrati d'un personnage très haut
en couleurs avec beaucoup de verve qui
jouait il était en représentation
un petit peu à chaque fois
c'est la première fois que je vois ça il
tapote le micro avant que ça commence
pour voir si ça marche bien et c'est
très professionnel dans le box sedrati
et sûr de lui provocateur malgré les
faits qui l'accablent il tient tête à
tout le monde
qu'il est il est lille est prolixe il
n'avait pas parlé il suffit de le
brancher sur un sujet et puis il vous
tient pendant pendant pendant pendant 30
minutes en minutes on est obligé on
oblige l'interrompt il dit la présidente
écoutez madame la présidente c'est moi
qui mène les débats non ça suffit un
fauve laisser parler c'est moi qui mène
les n'est pas bon c'est tellement
inattendu on sait pas trop quoi dire
sedrati ne déroge pas à sa ligne de
défense il n'est qu'un petit escroc et
il n'a jamais tué personne
face à ses accusateurs il a réponse à
tout et n'hésite pas à apostropher
certains témoins les témoins qu qui
venait et puis on jamais ce témoin l'a
échappé belle un ancien détenu parce que
nadir sedrati aurait pu
attenter à sa vie sedrati leur disais
logiquement lors de l'audience de corée
simba toi tu es vivant qu'est ce que tu
me reproches
c'est quelqu'un qui ne nie pas
le fait d'être un escroc c'est quelqu'un
qui ne nie pas usurpé l'identité des
gens mais il s'est jamais rendu coupable
d'aucun assassinat
pourtant nadir sedrati va finir par
perdre de sa superbe
[Musique]
au troisième jour du procès l'accusation
frappe un grand coup elle demande que la
broyeuse découverte dans le studio de
nadir sedrati soient présentés aux jurés
montré une broyeuse aux jurés c'est un
effet l'audience et regarder les
cadavres ont été broyés avec cette
machine
confronté à la broyeuse nadir sedrati
change de visage
cette joyeuse qui est énorme qui trône
devant le président il ne la supporte
pas et ne supporte pas la vue de cette
broyeuse et ils demandent formulé
plusieurs demandes afin qu'elles soient
remises et en dehors d'eux
delande la cour d'assises sedrati
devient nerveux la broyeuse affirme-t-il
n'a pas servi à découper des corps mais
seulement des blocs de cocaïne
suffit de regarder la tête des jurés
quand notamment il a inventé cette
histoire de trafiquants de cocaïne qui
aurait pris son appartement comme
quartier général
personne n'est dupe le sort de nadir
sedrati semble jouer reste un dernier
mystère le mobile car l'homme a dérobé
très peu d'argent à ses victimes pour
l'accusation sa seule motivation semble
avoir été de dérober leur identité
sedrati c'est quoi c'est comme un coucou
c'est quelqu'un qui va prendre l'avis
des autres tu vas avec tous les
attributs parce que finalement qu'est ce
qui fait 3 fois rien c'est pas assez son
mobile ne peut pas être financier c'est
vraiment du cas du petit mais il ya un
côté je prends la vie des autres après
sept jours d'audience les jurés se sont
fait leurs convictions le verdict va
être rendue
[Musique]
le 3 mai 2002 après seulement deux
heures de délibération c'est un verdict
sévère qui est prononcée la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité assortie de 20
ans de sûreté c'est la peine qui lui a
été infligé pour l'assassinât de trois
anciens codétenus nadir sedrati est
reconnu coupable des meurtres de hanz
gassen gérard stèles et norbert ronfort
sa peine de sûreté rallongé à 22 ans
lors du procès en appel
l'homme purge aujourd'hui sa peine au
centre de détention de moulins dans
l'allier mais la même question demeure
toujours pourquoi sedrati at il tué et
découpé trois hommes
voler l'identité de ces victimes
était-il réellement sa seule motivation
ni les policiers ni les magistrats ni
même les experts psychiatres n'ont
jamais fourni de réelles explications
[Musique]